from the fiery dishes of Sichuan to the
Bold flavors of Hunan Chili Peppers are
not just a spice they are the sole of
Chinese cuisine but why do the Chinese
love Chili Peppers so much is it just
about the Heat or is there a deeper
secret behind their Obsession beyond
their love for Spice Chinese Farmers
have developed unique methods to
cultivate and harvest Chili Peppers how
do they grow these vibrant fiery red
peppers that spice up millions of meals
every day join us as we uncover the
Journey of this National Spice from Farm
to Table and explore why Chili Peppers
have become an Irreplaceable part of
Chinese life
[Music]
spicy the chili growing process begins
with selecting highquality seeds these
seeds undergo treatments such as soaking
in warm water and germination
stimulation before being sewn in modern
Farms green houses and automated
nurseries help control temperature and
humidity ensuring uniform and healthy
seedling growth seed trays are placed on
automated Conveyor Systems that provide
precise watering and nutrient
distribution this ensures each plant
receives optimal conditions for strong
development after 20 to 30 days in the
nursery seedlings are ready to be
transplanted into the fields
traditionally Farmers planted chilies by
hand but today automated transplanting
machines have revolutionized the process
by digging furrows and placing seedlings
at consistent intervals covering roots
with a thin layer of soil for protection
integrating drip irrigation systems to
supply water and nutrients automatically
optimizing growth with modern technology
chili farming has become more efficient
increasing yields while conserving water
and fertilizer for sustainable
[Music]
agriculture after 3 to 4 months chilies
are ready for Harvest depending on their
intended use fresh or dried chilies
Farmers choose the most suitable
harvesting
[Music]
method large scale Farms use modern
chili harvesting machines to speed up
collection these machines either cut the
plant or shake it to dislodge the fruits
then filter and gather them into
containers while this method reduces
labor costs it has not yet completely
replaced manual labor
[Music]
for premium chili varieties or when
careful selection is required manual
harvesting remains essential workers
pick each chili by hand to prevent
damage to the plant and ensure the
highest quality despite advancements in
automation manual harvesting continues
to play a vital role especially for
specialty chilies that require careful
handling spicy
[Music]
after harvesting chilies are thoroughly
washed and sorted the process begins by
blending chilies with ingredients such
as vinegar salt garlic and sugar the
mixture is then cooked at a controlled
temperature to achieve the desired
consistency and rich flavor afterward
the chili sauce is sterilized and
bottled using an automated system to
ensure food safety and hygiene
[Music]
[Laughter]
bell peppers are washed inspected for
quality and sorted by size they are then
packed into bags or plastic containers
and stored in a temperature controlled
environment to maintain freshness before
being transported to supermarkets
[Music]
Chinese cuisine is renowned for its
perfect balance of spicy salty sweet and
sour flavors with chili peppers playing
a key role from the wfy Sichuan Hot Pot
to the crispy laziji spicy fried chicken
chilies do more than just add heat they
awaken the taste buds the Chinese use
various forms of chili including fresh
chilies dried chilies chili oil and
chili powder to create deep aromatic
flavors this unique combination results
in dishes that are not only delicious
but also addictive leaving diners
craving for more on
[Music]
fire beyond the vast fields of vibrant
red chilies onions are another another
indispensable ingredient in Cuisine
thanks to Advanced agricultural
technology Farmers have optimized the
process of growing and harvesting onions
significantly improving both yield and
quality onions are cultivated from seeds
or bulbs and to ensure uniform growth
modern Farms utilize automated seedling
systems in specialized greenh houses or
nurseries onion seeds are sewn with high
Precision using machines allowing
seedlings to develop healthily drip
irrigation systems and temperature
control help maintain stable moisture
levels creating optimal conditions for
young plants to
[Music]
[Laughter]
thrive once the plants reach a height of
around 15 cm they are transplanted into
the fields Advanced onion planting
machines ensure precise spacing between
plants allowing their roots to Anchor
firmly into the soil for optimal growth
automated irrigation systems continue to
provide water and nutrients as needed
enabling onions to grow robustly with
minimal manual
[Music]
labor during harvest season instead of
relying on labor intensive manual
methods large Farms use specialized
onion harvesting machines these machines
efficiently pull onions from the ground
remove excess soil and trim unnecessary
leaves the harvested onions are then
placed on conveyor belts for sorting
packaging and distribution to wholesale
markets or processing plants with the
support of modern machinery onion
farming has become more efficient
ensuring the highest quality produce
reaches
Consumers Electric
[Music]
truck by combining traditional expertise
with modern technology onion farming and
harvesting have not only increased
productivity but also ensured the
highest product quality from vast fields
to family dining tables onions are not
just a staple ingredient but also a
testament to The Continuous advancement
of modern agriculture electric truck